ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show it is christmas night right
it's the 26th night what does that mean
so it's the night after christmas
it's the night after christmas so
christmas is the 25th
oh that's correct and then which i know
and then the 26th is what
um like
aren't you religious what is it supposed
to be is it something
it's the day it's gotta be sad i guess
it's the first day of jesus's life
right shut up i hope everyone enjoyed
their holiday we have a great interview
with andrew schultz coming up we just
got back from new york city we went to
new york
for a few days uh to see my parents to
surprise
both of my parents to do a socially
distanced uh
truncated holiday which is really the
way i want to do them from now on
10 minutes socially distanced you're
live i'm alive okay
cool bye we're out of there i surprised
my mother who's in a mental institution
by the way
everyone's like she's gonna be so
surprised i'm like she's insane it's not
gonna be that much of a surprise
every day she they just go today is
another thing and she goes okay
she's in an institution i'm sure she was
i'm sure the level of surprise was
somewhat muted you know i was i told her
i'm sorry trump lost she felt very bad
about that she goes i know i know
and we got to do it through a plate of
glass like she's a felon
because of corona so i gotta covet
whatever you gotta stand i like corona i
like calling it the old school yeah i
like that
i gotta stand outside the plate glass
window and then she kept demeaning ben
she kept going i was like yeah ben's my
co-producer she's like oh you're
secretary
like not really he's he edits all my
content she's like your secretary i'm
like well
my best friend she's like your secretary
he's a secretary
like well you know certainly some of his
duties are secretarial i mean there's
you know but you you you took it in
stride she's a lovely woman
you took it in stride i think she
thought it was funny to keep calling me
a secretary i could see her smiling yeah
you you you
need to be beaten and people realize
that
if someone gives you too many
compliments the things you will do the
horror you will bring upon the world
would be uh unquantifiable this is true
the nightmares that you if you are not
constantly made to feel bad about who
you are
you are not at your best it's true it's
true it's a fact
some people just need it and then we
went to see my father
and uh the woman he married those two
goons
they just uh built a new house uh they
didn't build it they bought a new house
two blocks away from their old house
because they were bored
during the quarantine and because as
always they have no money and they're
perpetual victims and life is hard so
they bought a new house that's big
not as big as my house that doesn't
matter it does
and they uh they're living there now
in a lovely idyllic kind of town
you know we go there we surprise my
father you know the first thing he says
he looks at me goes
you know what's so nice here he goes
during the summer
the kids all throw water balloons at the
fire trucks on the fourth of july
he goes this real americana i'm like oh
that's nice why didn't we live here when
i was growing up
why didn't you give a [ __ ] about that i
was growing up doing cocaine
at 13 years old in in my best friend's
house whose mother was a prostitute
and we were doing blow where was your
care about americana back then
where was santa claus in the fire truck
back then you didn't give a [ __ ]
now you care that you're 70 and you have
no children
him and his chick their kids are gone
they've all been raised and they're out
of the house now they've decided to get
a
what a great place to raise ours no
children
what a great place to raise our dogs our
dogs
and then my stepmother who i've you know
we've had issues but i mean
we're fine you know i you know i have no
issue with anybody
but she likes to dig she digs
and many of you know this because you
have family members that do this they
give a compliment
which is actually uh the worst thing
you've ever heard
they give you a compliment and then
follow it up with the meanest someone
can be to you
they try to find your weaknesses isolate
them and then attack
which is what the woman does she she
started with me she goes oh you gotta
you got a nice big house i said yeah she
goes
are you all alone there
she doesn't even ask like that she goes
like this she goes first she goes
so does ben live with you i'm like no
ben lives with his wife and
oh she goes oh so you're alone in the
house i'm like yeah i'm a lunch because
does it get lonely there
and i'm like no it's fine i like it i
live alone a lot of people live alone
doesn't it's not a big deal but she's
just going she's digging in
and then she goes at him she goes she
goes so you
work with him she goes how did you meet
and he goes why why he's a comedian in
l.a she goes
oh so you used to do comedy she goes you
don't really do comedy anymore
and ben's like no my desk well he works
with tim and they do this whole thing
and
she goes oh so you don't do your own
comedy
anymore like again just trying to needle
and then he it says to work on him
he starts to get like sad he goes i'm
just a laugh track
i'm just a laugh track that's all i do
and i'm like god damn it no
don't let her do this then she starts
talking about her own daughter she goes
my daughter lives in a small apartment
and doesn't have any friends
she goes the law firm's keeping her very
busy but she doesn't have any friends
because she hasn't lived in long island
in a decade
and the only joy in her life is when me
and your father take her out for dinner
i'm like well i'm sure that's not true
i'm sure that's completely untrue and if
she's having such a hard time of it in
life
why are you telling me this god
keep it in but she likes that she likes
to spread
horror she does i mean that's just what
it is and poor little ben was like i'm
like ben runs our company ben does
everything
and ben was just like i'm just a laugh
track
i'm just a laugh track that's all i do
and i'm just like where you could tell
she doesn't work on me i don't care i go
yeah i like being alone
and then we start telling all about
patreon and all the money that we make
and everything
just because i would never do that but
the way i i only behaved in that manner
because
she it angered her it angers them when i
talk about money
that angers them right um
[Music]
but but we were in and out of there what
10 minutes
yeah 10 minutes both of us thoroughly
insulted
and this is what you this is what you
can do instead of doing the whole
holiday party
because holidays are fun if you have
little kids and you give them batman it
goes daddy i love you
that's not it for a lot of us for a lot
of us it's going to a family
sitting around a room with a bunch of
people with drinking problems
and divorcees multiple bankruptcies
people don't even know who each other
are anymore you're like who are you
again you're dating who
you're your uncle
[ __ ] rick's girlfriend you've been
seeing each other how long like
no one knows you it's like it's also i'm
a divorced family so i don't even know
the uncle whose girlfriend this is
like uh yeah i'm sharon i date steve
who's steve
what are we all doing here it's a waste
of our time
everybody's like one you know we're all
like somehow
this is this odd configuration of human
beings in
a a divorced family where people have
several marriages and different children
it's a have you ever been at these
holiday parties where like
the kids come in like after they were
with their other
family this is true it's like the
saddest thing
it's like and now the kids are back from
dads
and the kids run in all manic and they
and they have to start like they fling
their
jackets off and then they grab their
presents
and then they like they're like i'm now
i'm enjoying my second
christmas with this other family i
really don't know
it's so weird and then they introduce
the kids to you
and you're like hey whatever their names
are you know
hey ralph no one's name ralph but you
know what i mean i don't
there's too many of their real names for
me to use even though i do talk about
i don't know why i'm shielding the
children but i feel like it just makes
sense
but then you look at them and they're
like you know some i love like the
the the girls who are kind of [ __ ] like
the like girls and they're like early
teens or whatever
like this is tim this is timmy's son and
they're just like they say go
you know and i'm like yeah merry
christmas
mary i don't know why i'm here merry
christmas i hate
this
it's such a i mean the christmases have
just gotten tragic
and then people you barely know hand you
garbage gifts
they hand you [ __ ] gifts my stepmother's
father once gave me a hard drive i'm
like what is this
the zapruder film it was [ __ ]
he goes it's it just says all these
facts because you're a comedian you
should know a bunch of facts
it was just endless pages of facts about
everything you could think about
really yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on here
what is this
but you don't know these people they
shouldn't even be giving you gifts and
yet they are
you just fall out of families you fall
out
like i said to ben like ben is my family
because like my mom's not
i'm like dad i love him but he's had a
lobotomy i mean he's been mcmurphy he's
talking about his dogs and then his wife
maleficent is trying to ruin our lives
here
she's trying to just destroy any
semblance of self-respect me and this
kid have
and then i i i choose that or my lunatic
mother
you know in a stop the steel hat with
tina 40.
so and i know and my cousins and my god
listen to this
my cousin okay the ones that aren't
in jail currently text me and goes
hey i don't ask for much by the way
good i don't ask for anything
so when you go i don't ask for much i go
good please don't change
that please have that be the only text
hey i don't ask for much
oh noted merry christmas
but then he goes like this i'm gonna
read the text
it's out of his goddamn mind these
people
and i love everyone and respect them but
i have to let everyone know
listen to this listen throwing this out
there i don't ask for much
i don't have a twitter and budweiser is
doing this thing if you send them a pic
of your dog they will put it
on their beer can can you send this
picture to budweiser
and send the hashtag pupwiser
hashtag put what aren't you in recovery
why do you want a dog on a can of
budweiser
what's the next thing you want me to do
get a picture of your dog on a syringe
you want an oxycont with a picture of
your cat get to work folks
i've had enough
then he goes you know i'll save the
trouble if you answer
i'll just go [ __ ] myself correct love
the little guy but enough
no i'm not putting your dog on a can of
budweiser
many people in our family have wet brain
because of that product
okay there's people that can't stand up
straight without getting vertigo
yeah i don't think we should put your
puppy on a on a beer bottle
enough with the substances for christ
[ __ ] irish slobs one at all
my skin looks horrible because i just
got back from new york and i'm related
to these people
and i believe my emotions bleed out of
my face that's why i
uploaded that photo of the studio and
everyone's [ __ ] on me because i look
so bad so bad get it up and show them
how bad i look
i want you to know how bad i look and i
know i don't look good now
but i looked horrible i looked good a
week ago though many of you commented on
that
look oh wait go how much did the vaccine
one get that's fun
25 000. oh that's just fun though this
is me getting the vaccine can we play
that yeah of course
my own goddamn twitter
this is me getting the vaccine
come on i got the vaccine yesterday and
i feel great
thank you for the vaccine i'm very happy
about the vaccine and i feel good
just fun now look at this photo i mean
and can you do the close-up mm-hmm
do a close-up on me in this photo if you
can it is so
hard go in deep yes
further further as i can go
find a way to go further okay hold on
this is so harrowing and ben looks great
by the way
adding nothing as he usually does
i it is so harrowing this photo of
myself
that i was so i didn't want to post it
but i'm like
i'm gonna have to post it and i did
and i just took my medicine because
people
people were honestly like this is
horrific
and they were right but it was a boss
picture sometimes you gotta look
my god my god look at that
man look at that
everything is the hair the gray the
blotchiness
the breakout the fat [ __ ] like
everything came together the expression
the bags under the eyes everything came
together
for just a a moment of horror
a corpse an irish corpse
better looking than 75 percent of irish
women though let's be honest
that's what an irish woman looks like
when she gets older that's the best
you're gonna do if someone's named terry
or colleen
but what a horror if you're not if
you're not
if you're not watching this should go to
my instagram and you'll see it get it
away please
but i was in new york and because i have
to deal now thank god we were able to go
to artie's
south shore fish in island park which
reopened
it is the best fish restaurant on long
island
still they've got the same chef they've
got the same fish guy
it is truly amazing and i'm happy to
have gone there to have flown across the
country
flown across the country to have
patronized such an establishment and i
think that that's a great thing that we
did
there it is artie's south shore fish in
a blizzard
no less and we did it
the tuna tartare buffalo calamari shrimp
cocktail
tuna tidbits baby crab cakes any of the
fishes their soul is great they have
everything you go in there you say what
came in today
what's fresh halibut whatever you get a
little white wine
lemon get some potatoes maybe a sweet
potato a little spinach boom you're done
it's great don't shut down more
restaurants please
stop shutting down restaurants
they have done so much work the
government has done nothing
the government has spent eight months
twiddling their [ __ ] thumbs
they haven't passed a relief bill they
haven't done anything
they haven't they haven't they've not
increased icu capacity
they haven't built more hospitals
they've done nothing restaurants on the
other hand
have worked their asses off trying to
operate safely
they've done they've spent tons of money
to put outdoor dining
in they put those glass partitions up
between tables they went through all of
these different regulations
okay they want to keep their customers
safe they want to keep their employees
safe they work harder
than the government and gavin newsom and
andrew cuomo and the other scumbags
who run these states uh are shutting
them down
and destroying their ability to earn a
living and earn money and i know it's a
real disease
and i know it is spiking but there has
to be
a better way to do this than to destroy
people's livelihoods
forever and then let all this [ __ ]
money
these bailouts that get passed go to
corporate america and jimmy dore did a
whole great thing on this where he goes
this is an upward transfer wealth which
i i spoke to mullen when this first
happened and after 9 11 after all of
these things after the
the mortgage crisis there just is this
massive transfer of wealth
upwards to the most powerful people the
least vulnerable people in our society
are rewarded and the most vulnerable
people in our society are [ __ ]
people that work people that work at
[ __ ] food
uh distribution centers that you know
the tyson
chicken factory people that have to have
to go to work essential workers
restaurant workers people that are
earning a living um
not in their house like we are lucky
enough to do they're out there [ __ ]
actually going out
and earning a [ __ ] living and by the
way everybody has a problem with comics
doing shows nobody has a problem with
people working at ralph's because they
don't give a [ __ ] about those people
okay
nobody has a problem with that nobody
has a problem with other
workers that are going out doing
essential oil i know there's good
arguments why comics shouldn't do shows
i'm not doing shows right now i
hopefully will get back to them in march
okay
um but there also has to be an
understanding like for some people there
was never a quarantine
those people never had the luxury of
being off okay
whether they worked at a grocery store
or a place like walmart
or target or whatever it was or they
drove an uber
or a lyft and they had to earn [ __ ]
money and
it's just disgust i mean what is left to
do
with people like nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer
and mitch mcconnell other than publicly
execute them
and i know and i say that as an
intellectual exercise
but what is left to do with this
government right now
truly what is left to do with the
government these are these people
have ordered businesses to shut down
they have not provided any relief
and then they are they go and give you
tours of their freezer
like that that that old witch nancy
pelosi did seven months ago where she's
walking around showing you that she's
got gelato in the freak what
what can be done with these people
other than to to draw and quarter them
catholic inquisition style put them on
iraq
i mean honestly why are these people
still around
why in god's name is nancy pelosi she's
the wicked witch
of the west's sister like she's the one
where you just saw the feet furl up yeah
yeah
why is she there why is chuck schumer
these people they don't leave they have
been a part
of these wealth transfers jimmy dore
that great kind of viral clip
they've engineered them yeah republicans
and democrats have engineered these
things they think
they think these things are great so
i don't know what's left to do truly and
i i would
never and i'm not now advocating any
type of violence but i do understand
people's frustration and they go
what do you do with a government that
has just really completely failed on on
every level here
you got to vote all of these people out
i guess i mean that's the only thing
you can really do they are truly uh
enemies of the public good in in every
way
they are enriching themselves and their
friends at the expense of everybody else
there was a way to do this
there was a way to do masks and
distancing and compromising
and building more icus and building more
beds and increasing hospital
uh capabilities and maybe invoking the
defense production act
using companies that didn't
traditionally make medical equipment and
ppe to start doing it
there were ways to do all of this there
were ways to do it and we didn't do it
we failed at every level
from trump on down to laurie lightfoot
who's leading chicago
can you get up lori lightfoot when she
dressed up on halloween
lori lightfoot halloween costume this
year please
as she came in as like the defeater of
corona or something
she she came in
are these people are these people insane
this is the your government these
people are running major american cities
but she had another costume it was like
there was something even
more oh the rona destroyer yes the rona
destroyer
this is laurie life was the mayor of
chicago
as the rona just
i mean the woman runs the city of
chicago
not like a little town she's running the
city of chicago
dressed in a cape that's just the rona
destroyer
go get up gavin newsom get up this loser
go to dinner party put get the image on
that this is gavin newsom's dinner party
that he was at the french laundry which
is a phenomenal restaurant
this is it right here there it is
everybody an indoor dinner party which
has been covered at nauseum
and i don't want to spend a lot of time
on it but i just want to say there he is
at an indoor dinner party resign resign
no i'm not kidding yes resign who's the
mayor of austin and did the same thing
yeah he flew to cabra
resign yeah resign if you break your own
lockdown rule that is impoverishing and
destroying the lives of people
in order to supposedly save them you
need to resign
look at this criminal yeah who's this
the mayor of what
austin god yep
steve adler yeah resign
truly if you're going to do this you
have to resign yeah
i mean i i don't you know i know they
never will these people never relinquish
power
at all but you have to resign if you're
staunchly pro-lockdown
that's your position but you have to not
go and do
dinner parties at the french laundry and
take planes to cabo
you can't do it you can't ask everybody
you can't destroy people's lives
and then go out and party
how are the holidays how are the holiday
shopping numbers
how are the retail numbers well john
let's see
that's the old thing we pulled up too
it's it says it's doing good i mean
the economy's doing great you know the
dow hit 30 000. no i mean
there's i'm sure there's numbers at the
end of this there we're going to find
the numbers you know
after the holiday season is over people
are going to look back at the earnings
how it always is and they're going to go
yeah
there's probably a week i mean look at
the unemployment what are the
unemployment numbers right now ben i
mean it's like the craziest thing i've
ever seen in my life
unemployment rate is
people are filing claims every week
and it's really really bad you know i
mean it's really
really really bad it's gone down but
it's going back
up again we got to find out how many
people
try to find out how many people filed
for unemployment last week
if we had jamie vernon we'd have it up
this will take another hour i hope
nobody has anything to do
i hope nobody has anything to do it's
just another two or three hours here
before we get it in
thank you ben 751
000 people filed for jobless claims last
week you know the week before that was
000. and two of those [ __ ]
should be gavin newsom
and that guy in austin truly i mean
this is [ __ ] it's crazy
outdoor dining in l.a should not be
closed down it accounts for such a small
percentage of transmission outdoor
dining in the sun
in la should not be shut down indoor
dining i don't know enough about it but
i know that when we're in new york
and we're eating in [ __ ] these weird
vestibules they've built these like
stables on the street these stalls
that look like a horse would go in but
we're eating in it
and we're eating in 35 degree weather
but it's again it's a building
you have insulation to a degree it's not
insulated and warm
but you're seeing yourself i'm in a
[ __ ] building it's a mind [ __ ]
like i'm in a building on the street
instead of in a building
so i don't get it why not invest in
better air filtration systems we could
have done all of this
yeah we could have done all of this but
we didn't do anything
and trump has been no [ __ ] help he's
out i mean he's over it
you know and um it's just frustrating
it's frustrating because it's going to
be a very
it's going to be a tough holiday season
for a lot of people my father
is in the wine business and it's doing
very well because a lot of people are
drinking but a lot of his friends are in
the restaurant business and they're
suffering and they're all scared about
another shutdown they're like if there's
another shutdown we're all [ __ ]
i don't think a lot of people can handle
another shutdown especially in that
industry
you know so it's going to be
difficult my stepmother now works from
home permanently lucky
him i'm lucky my dad um but it's
you know listen
it's it's it's it's a tough season so
we've got to find a way to do have you
found a way for us to do charity i mean
no you're smiling you're smiling but
it's i ask you to do it a lot
yeah i researched the best thing we can
do is find a church that
that we like and the church of satan
the best thing we can do is directly go
to the people like you said so we need
to find a church that we like
and go door-to-door give people you know
there's canned food there's rent relief
things like that i'm trying not to throw
out a general
thing but that's what we should do so we
don't have to give to one of these
big companies so we go to work let me
ask you a few questions
we go to a church and they give us
people's addresses we show them the
house
well you go with a well you're supposed
to go with a group of people but now i'm
what do you mean we good we got covered
out there and we don't
have any friends what do you think about
a group of people you want me to go
little zan what what are we doing here
you want me and candace owens to knock
on doors what group
you go door to door you ask people for
canned food if they have any canned food
they don't need you take that and then
you give it to people that need it
like wait a minute wait a minute this is
the
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
[ __ ] life where did you read this you
go to someone's house and you ask them
for canned food we used to
give it to someone else we did this in
texas why didn't you just buy the canned
food it's 10 cents or you can go buy
canned food too
totally yeah it seems crazy to go knock
on someone's door you have any corn
you're not using i want to redistribute
it it's small towns of texas it's not
that insane
because it's like everybody knows
everybody you know you knock you go hey
donna you got
any you know any green beans or
something
okay i'll give you the benefit of the
doubt there i i
i don't know where the hell i'm gonna do
where am i gonna walk around beverly
hills
hi hey
first of all beautiful home this is
stunning did you just buy
i've been here two years what a two
years it's been i know
anyway so me and my producer are
thank you oh my well it is familiar
because i'm on
i'm on podcast a lot well rogan i'm a
regular on that my own show is kind of
big and
right thank you i put lights out with
david spade no
you saw that you saw lights out with
david spain
well yeah well thank you i think i was
one of the funnier ones many of the
people that went in there
they're on drugs let's be honest and
they don't work but i
really appreciate that you said all
those kind things
me and my producer i guess who you know
right you're a fan
are trying to do a like a charity
where if you have any extra
i haven't eaten i have not eaten at all
actually i'm
craigs you ordered cracks that's amazing
it's too much for you for one per hey
i mean pinch my you know come on i'll
eat some crags
if you ordered craig's that's that's
phenomenal okay
and you've got some of the pints of the
vegan peanut butter chip ice cream
i'd love to see the backyard i'll i
would absolutely love to see the
backyard
oh well me and my producer were just
doing um
we're doing like a a charity she did get
fat
she got very fat and i think that's why
she's not working
she's very fat and it's why she's not
working right now and it's sad because
i think it's it's booze fat it's that
flabby booze fat
it's not you know you don't look at her
and go she's full of a christmas roast
you go she's full of cheap fuel
if you know what i mean like gasoline
that type of thing yeah but i mean i've
met her a few times but
there's a [ __ ] oh i don't care [ __ ] her
[ __ ] her and a husband i don't give a
[ __ ] about any of it yeah
well no me and my producer were trying
to collect
food for uh needy people
uh i thought oh my god i know it was
crazy did they come down the street
did they come down the street chanting
oh my god eat the rich on this street
i mean it's disgusting of course it's
the universities
it's absolutely the universities
absolutely
i would love one and evian is fine thank
you
it's the universities and i've said it
before there's a lot of problems
in the schools and we've kind of let
them get insane and i love
dogs i love them i love them yeah
a shih tzu they're fun it's a very
beverly hills dog
isn't it you know it just kind of just
sits on a couch i love
is this ovo leather it's very soft
yes it's very very soft oh the guy's
here he's here
ben get the craigs that'll do he'll get
it he doesn't mind no he doesn't
oh you you have one okay get okay
thank you thank you nadja bomban
yes well it's i mean listen it's
it's so great to to meet you and this
has been so enjoyable
absolutely oh we were just trying to
figure out like a like a charity or
something or oh it's very interesting so
you actually
have a charity interesting
so what are you trying to do okay so
you're trying to like
interesting fashion for women in
afghanistan
so smart so smart
and you own so you own some textile
mills okay
and you're just trying to kind of
because if people look good and feel
good of course
i well listen are you doing a dinner for
it okay
here's the deal take my information
let me know if you ever want to do you
know i'll come we'll do a dinner i love
if you ever need a comedian to kind of
lighten things up when you have one of
these dinners
let's try to build more textile
factories
so we can churn out some kind of fashion
forward
clothing for those women in afghanistan
without clits
that sounds great well it's good to meet
you i lo
you can't go wrong with craigs let me
what am i going to do
that's door-to-door in this in this town
yeah
what do you mean door-to-door ben
avery's door-to-door
lucy you know me it's tough to quit
smoking cigarettes but i've been really
helped by lucy lucy is a lozenge
okay it comes in three cool flavors
winter green cinnamon pomegranate it is
a lozenge that has four milligrams of
nicotine
and it allows you to gradually step down
so you could turn yourself into a
non-smoker
you don't have to vape you don't have to
do any other crazy stuff you don't have
to eat
you know waffle sundaes and bacon
cheeseburgers
what we want you to do is basically try
to
gradually you know remove your
dependence
on nicotine it's a company founded by
caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner
nicotine alternative okay finally
tobacco alternatives that really don't
suck
they've got a lot of cool flavors so
it's 20 20 get rid of the cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal a subscription to
lucy comes directly to your door each
month it's so simple you don't have to
leave your house because lucy has
delivery down
timberland listeners go to lucy.co use
promo code tim
get 20 off all products lucy.co and use
promo code tim to get 20
all off all products including gum or
lozenges
that's lucy.co and use promo code tim at
checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
higher side chats we talked about this
the other day this is really a great
podcast about conspiracies it's hosted
by greg karlwood
friends of mine will send me some of his
episodes i listen to a great one on
underground military bases
he's got everything okay i mean ancient
civilization seeker
uh graham hancock he's got people like
whitney webb
i mean secret societies false flags
alien moon bases tesla technology
the coven 1984 agenda the higher side
chats encourages people to hear
from counter culture scholars authors
doctors and interesting characters that
don't have a voice in the mainstream
and see how that perspective and
research stands up to the puppet masters
carefully
crafted monoculture use the coupon code
tim dillon for a free month of the
higher side chats premium
go to the highersidechats.com to sign up
coupon code tim dillon
for free month of the higher side chats
premium i'm telling you i don't really
plug a lot of [ __ ]
but this guy's got a great interview
style he loves smoking weed
he loves mixing it up with these people
and these
these episodes are pretty damn
interesting it's a cool pace he's
relaxed
there's a lot of podcasts i want to
advertise on here and i don't take the
ads usually
but this show that i've heard i don't
listen all the time i don't listen to
anything all the time
but i've heard this show i've enjoyed it
i think greg callwood is a great style
of interviewing people
and i think this is a very interesting
show even if you don't agree with this
or believe it you know you know
you don't have to believe anything i
think the strength of the show is if if
you don't believe any of it is it still
entertaining and it is that shows a
great show
so go to the highersidechats.com to sign
up and you use the copa
coupon code tim dillon for a free month
you know i can help people privately but
it's hard to
give money to an organization i really
don't trust the red cross
and i really don't trust a lot of
different organizations
because i know how they're run and
they're not run well
and it's unfortunate um what is my
christmas present
your do you want to know your christmas
present me and katie talked about it
today oh stop this let me tell you right
now
though let me tell you how that let me
you want to see how that conversation
went
let's imagine him and his wife
discussing my christmas
no let's imagine that ready let's
imagine that let's have a full fun
let's have a little fun imaging
i guess we have to get tim the christmas
present
bam he's the fat ogre and he abuses you
you don't need to get him anything you
should cut his throat while he sleeps
k i will do that but
before i have you know another
opportunity
we should probably get him like
something he'll like
like a big bowl of pancake batter
that he can just cook and eat because
he's
he's a pig man can we give him something
and poison him
he's destroyed your life he's destroyed
our lives you're supposed to be the
biggest arena comedian in america
and now you're working for this fat near
duel i hate him he's disgusting
so you discuss the present by the way
that is the exact
word-for-word conversation that happens
in that home
that's the exact that's why he's
laughing
it's word for word what happens in that
home
he does nothing but take advantage of
you and a beauja
he's the worst
so what what uh christmas present have
you and the mrs
cooked up for me i'm such a lucky boy
well i'm such a lucky man i know you so
much better she was like what if i
got like a framed photo of like all the
studios you guys have been in over the
years like from the porch to the
and i was like no he'll hate that she's
like well what does he like i'm like
well he likes
rolls royces yeah so she was like
i like more than that now you're
cheapening me you're making me into a
cartoon and a character but you love
rolls-royce
who doesn't it's not a knock on you no
i'm not
i don't think it is but it's so we were
either going to get you i almost like
people that don't plot to kill me
people don't plot the poise of me for
christmas you want the cia to not kill
you
yeah well cia you and her whoever
so uh like a collectible the the
rolls-royce continental like uh
because i can't get you an actual so
you're gonna get me a little car
yeah yeah but you love looking at the
rolls royces i love them you look
well that's sweet yeah or an ornament a
rolls-royce ornament katie
mentioned which was funny because of the
the ornament that
the the greyhound ornament is it's just
funny that she even mentioned that she's
what about a rolls-royce ornament well i
think that if you and her got all of
your money together and got some loans
you'd probably get me an old rolls-royce
how much are how much are old voices go
look it up right now
look it up right now i think you could
you could get you could go really old
you could get let's look at the
rolls-royce pasadena here
pre-owned yeah let's see well
wait 123 000. is that it yeah
i mean ben let's be honest
you're going to get me an ornament why
don't you do the real thing
go back up what year is that what year
is that 126.
the ghost 2011.
18 000 miles that's it i mean i got to
be honest with you why didn't i buy that
why did i get this dumb range rover
the [ __ ] wrong with me that is pretty
sick dude let me look at that again
yeah it's nice i mean dude
what the [ __ ] dude 2013 ghost can i see
that yeah yeah
dude what if i s what if i sell the
range i get the ghost
all right this isn't good broadcast i'm
not getting it rolls royce ghost but i
think you and your wife should
for me we'll get you one one day
a lot of talk you know your christmas
present
is it what your spanish teacher used to
say
she used to say mr dillon you've got the
robin's egg again you get zero
no here's your christmas present
you know what it is it's a job
we wish you a merry christmas we wish
you a merry christmas
we wish you a merry christmas
you continue to have a job
that's right cratchit
you still have a job we literally had a
thanksgiving where it was cratchit where
he wanted
thanksgiving morning i needed him to
move furniture out of whitney cummings
house
and he couldn't because him and his wife
were doing some god only knows
thanksgiving brunch
and i and i so you know so i would i of
course
i'm like work grind help to you know get
the movers
give them money give everyone hit
everybody off give everyone and you know
him is very deeply selfish
so he had that uh cratchit moment where
he goes i don't need to work and i'll
just kind of loaf around
and then i'm like you should just come
to the job and he goes by i'll start
going to therapy and i'm like no that's
not it
that's his generation damn does that
[ __ ] too they're weak
and they go uh well just come through
he's like no you could just do the job
that you should be doing but
hey i appreciate the little car
the tiny little the the matchbox car
that you and your wife are gonna get me
well we haven't found it yet
well but hey i i this is why i love
christmas
this is why i love christmas because
i have shared with ben my my mind
my comedy my career my life
my you know all of my friends all of my
connections
i've taken him all over the country he's
met some fascinating people
and he has seen some of the most
interesting and exciting things
that have gone down in media and comedy
over the last two years
and i am very excited about my
matchbooks
my matchbook rolls royce that you and
your wife are going to give me a little
matchbook
card isn't it isn't it sweet
well it'll be bigger than that i want to
find like one that's like that big
i think it's hey i love it
i think it's sweet and that's what i
love about christmas
that's what i love about christmas is
that we can give each other the gifts
yes you know that's
why are you laughing it's just funny but
it is funny it is funny yeah yeah
it is because what are you gonna get me
it's hard to get me things right
it's very hard to get you things very
hard to get me something yeah so why not
a matchbook car
like a toy for child right like it's
like a child's toy
no like i thought you'd put it maybe
just get him out let him browse rise
that fat [ __ ]
hopefully he'll think it's food he'll
choke on it and die
i hate him ben i hope he dies
well i'm eagerly anticipating my
matchbook car
from my best friend and business partner
who will be giving me him and his wife
would say put thought into it
and decided that they wanted to get me a
little model car and
maybe maybe i'll get them a model train
set
fun andrew schultz has released a
four-part comedy special called schultz
saves america on
netflix he is incredibly funny he's also
very savvy
very smart he understands his business
better than many many people
and this episode is really good because
not only i think
will it entertain people that aren't in
this business but if you're a young
person
or or whatever age you are if you're a
creator if you're
in a business where you have to be
forward thinking and you've got to
evolve
um this is a very interesting
conversation about
how to evolve how to utilize things
uh like social media and youtube to
build kind of enough
uh you know traction equity whatever
so you can go out there and get larger
companies to [ __ ] with you it's an
interesting conversation and andrew
knows more about it than pretty much
anyone else you know so he's been able
to do some really amazing [ __ ]
and we talk about it for an hour then we
also go into other stuff too
um so as always we thank you for the
will we have another
we have another episode before the end
of the year no no no no no that's it
uh so the 26th and 27th 28th
no no i think our next episode it drops
on the second or third
this is the last one of the year yeah i
want to end with a thought
i would having this thought
because i am hopeful about things and i
i
how great would it be if new year's eve
coming up in about a week right
clock strikes 12. every
country decides to nuke us
at the same time i mean every single one
how great would that be great
for old acquaintances and just
every kind i mean little countries just
firing off whatever they got
just ever just nukes us at the same time
on new year's eve that'd be great
just an idea just a thought
um i mean it's such a crazy year to
really think about
where this show is what the show has
become
what was the first episode of last year
can you find it please
thank you this is crazy to think where
the show has grown and how much the show
has grown in a year
and the most insane year that i've ever
been a part of in my life
i want to know what the first episode
was last year
so our last one of the year was sal
volcano so then it was
let me see not there
it was the historians was the last one
and then low-cost high quality
the one we did in the car uh and that
was the first episode of last year
low-cost high quality yeah january 4th
this has been a year to
really remember for many reasons but
this show has grown
so dramatically in a year right yeah
i mean it's crazy insane um we
appreciate everybody that watches the
show that listens to it that tells their
friends and family about it
um this has been a crazy journey for us
we had no idea we'd be able to do the
things we are now doing
you know we're going all around the
country the shows are all sold out
we've been on the joe rogan experience
you know i've been on it now seven times
once with an election live stream and
once with one of the most epic podcasts
ever recorded sitting next to alex jones
it was
so cool one of the coolest things ever
me and ben used to sit in the garage
in california and watch people like
rogan
and watch alex and watch all these
people and wonder how we could catapult
ourselves into that reality
truly you know what i mean and um
and it's kind of amazing to see that
we've been able to do that
you know we've been able to do that
we've been able to kind of
claim some turf and from there be really
funny
about a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's
been happening a lot of dark stuff
that's been happening
and we've been as funny about it as we
can we can be and we've been doing that
for years but this year it really
it really kind of caught on you know and
um
you know we first met
in 2016. yes yeah
and we sat in that garage for a few
years
and just made [ __ ] and
talked and smoked cigarettes
and which i love right now
but it was tr it's truly amazing to be
here be in a new studio
you know and it's it's the most insane
professional journey i've ever been on
in my life
i've done specials i've sold pilots i've
i've shot pilots i've had
big people produce things that never
went anywhere i've done you know i've
toured i've done all this [ __ ] but the
building this show has been the most
insane
professional journey of my life and i'm
sure for you it's in the top five
you know i would hope um
but i mean do you want to say anything
somewhat
sincere about the show
now um do you want to get a matchbook
car for all the listeners
like oprah where they look under the sea
yeah get in my car
would you like to get a toy car for
everyone
um so i can say something sincere yes
um here's what i'll say
here's what i'll say about what
the direction we're moving in we're
we're very excited
no do it do it do it you're gonna say
something sincere no you'll just make
fun of me i'm not gonna make fun of you
i'm not gonna make fun of you this has
been the
the coolest thing ever it's so surreal
to go from the garage making sketches on
the iphone
because we didn't have a camera we
didn't have a computer we didn't have
any of this stuff and
and we still did it too it's been cool
to watch you
get successful and famous it's been
really exciting for me
and uh uh i love you a lot
that's what i wanted to say you wanted
me to be real
and i i thank you for everything well i
thank you
i know people think you hate me or
something but it's they don't get that
it's a joke and stuff but
it's been really cool to know you well
listen
i just want to say
that instead of saying all that you
could just show it to me by getting me a
small
model of a rolls royce that i could play
with on this desk
no i love you you're my only family on
earth literally
it's you yeah jake paul and candace
owens
no as your stepmother pointed out you
she was like so you guys only have each
other
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys are
losers you don't have any other friends
yeah well that's
yeah well you know
okay but she also looks like danny
aiello
so hey
so happy new year everybody i'm that by
the way i i can't even imagine anyone
from my family still talks to me
but i just don't lie um so many comics
out there just
they make [ __ ] up and they lie i just
talk about the [ __ ] that
i gotta talk about that is real to me
the fact that this show resonates with
people i guess i should
look at the fight there's all these
rules i gotta look at the camera wow
the fact that this show resonates with
people the fact that you guys [ __ ]
watch it and you and you send me photos
of
the fact you guys went and saw me and
dan out there when we were out there
performing live
and the fact that like you know you
you've allowed this show to grow to what
it is and hopefully it grows even more
is huge it is it is something that we
really enjoy doing
and um you know we we are grateful for
it i'm grateful for it
you know and i i think that we i don't
say that enough
you know because i'm trying to be funny
which is i'm you know that's the job of
me
um but we're definitely grateful for the
fact that you guys have been
as aggressive in supporting this show
not not only the patrons which we
appreciate the [ __ ] out of but
everybody who watches on youtube
everybody who shares it
this that and the other thing and um you
know the show's not gonna be like a
touchy-feely sentimental show
now but we just wanted for the end of
the year
you know i mean this guy loves me so
much he's got me a toy car
you see what i mean so i just want to
let you know that i appreciate you as
much as he appreciates me
and if you guys were here i would
too give you a toy car
of a car you can't afford so that you
could play with it like a child
or as my stepmother said i would i would
bring you into my home and uh you know
dress you down i'd dress
i would dress you down but for all of us
here at the tim dylan show
which is just literally all of us it's
just
it's ben and me that's all that's the
only team that really matters there's
other people on the team and they're
whatever you know we got agents and
managers and people that
we like and they're doing good jobs but
the reality is me and ben are the team
and we've taken this thing as as
you know we'll continue to take it um as
far as we can take it and you guys
allow us to take it you know because i
think
that if we really got smart here
we could turn this audience
into a violent militia not kidding
get out of here as guys so much of our
identity is wrapped up in our hair from
how it feels after getting a fresh cut
to the way it's perfectly styled before
going out
long story short you don't want to go
bald keeps is a great product that helps
you keep your
hair okay all of the all of the um
you know products out there hair
replacement things like that
none of them are good they don't look
good keeps helps you keep the hair that
you have right now
prevention is key okay keeps treatments
typically take between four and six
months to see results
so it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save find out what keeps us more
five-star reviews
than any of its competitors and more
than a hundred thousand men
trust keeps to keep their hair on their
head it's only ten dollars a month is
that i mean that's clearly worth
keeping your hair okay i mean
it really is you know i mean i have
friends that take this this is really
important
other comedians not gonna say who will
keep everyone's uh
anonymity whatever but i'll tell you
right now it's really good if you go to
keeps.com
tim dillon to receive your first month
of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon
k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon okay
and i'm telling you right now this is
the move
they have all the fda stuff in there but
it's cheaper
so this is the generic the two fda
approved
medications this is the generic cheaper
form you got it
you got to do it keeps
ridge wallet
i mean what can i say about ridge wallet
other than
that it is a wallet i have done this
advertisement now a trillion times
um i
love the ridge wallet it's a metal
wallet
get it out i got it right here all right
god
it is a front pocket wallet
okay you put it in your front pocket it
uh you keep your cards in there and your
cash in there
it's not a big clunky wallet with all
the [ __ ] it's a cool wallet
small sleek sexy
modern easy to sanitize
go get me some of the hand sanitizer
from the kitchen i want to do a
demonstration here
because people don't realize that we're
living in in
perilous times and i'm trying to show
you why the ridge wallet
is actually the safest i don't even know
why they don't put this in their ad copy
i mean it's like
uh who's working over there but here we
go
all other wallets we don't know how to
sanitize them right watch this
sanitizer goes in the hand here goes the
ridge
ridge wallet look at this look how easy
this is to sanitize
super easy your wallet has now been
sanitized
go to ridge.com t-i-m-ridge.com
tim use the code tim link in the
description that's ridge.com tim and use
code tim link in description
bravo's below deck is a show where
severely damaged people clean boats in
10 to millionaires it's very
entertaining this season the chef on
board started yelling eat my
cooter at the production crew and then
quit if you want to hear
three cis white males break down the
show then listen to another below deck
podcast
hosted by dylan pat and nick davis the
producer of this past weekend and the
king and the sting with the yvonne
if you like the bachelor they've got
another bachelor podcast nick dylan and
pat just got done with the most recent
season that was filmed this summer
quarantine at la quinta resort in palm
springs
it's not that nice it featured a bulimic
army that who tried to take his own life
no hate on the resort i've just been
nicer places i have my private home
uh it featured a bulimic army vet who
tried to take his own life twice in 2019
a former drug addict who was caught
trying to steal
his father's checks and an engineer
whose brother is a jailbird
with tear tattoos on his face
none of this is made up in any way the
next season of the bachelor featuring
the first black male lead in the show's
history starts next week and promises to
feature
and take advantage of equally as damaged
people as contestants okay
so go to another below deck podcast and
another bachelor podcast on apple
podcast and leave a five star review
that says tim dillon sent you okay
that's another below deck podcast
and another bachelor podcast and leave a
five-star review that said tim
dillon sent you ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the tim dillon show andrew
schultz is with us schultz saves america
trending right now on netflix
six part comedy series one part
four part
[Laughter]
it's on hulu right now it is a six-part
documentary
about andrew's parents and it is on
amazon prime dance studios
ballroom dance save america no it's four
part they're calling it a comedy special
yeah because it's funny yeah and it's
you it's kind of like your year in
review
yes exactly yeah yeah yeah and you were
doing these things on
instagram yeah and you were doing to
turn your phone everybody [ __ ] loved
them the rock was
wat like everybody was watching me real
cool about that and and
then you you got the opportunity to take
it to netflix how was it going from
instagram where you could do whatever
you want say whatever you want
to netflix because that's i think a big
question in people's heads like yeah
you're the independent guy you do and
say what you want yeah
you get away with a lot of [ __ ] too on
the netflix they they were great
okay they were great yeah legally it's
tricky
right there's certain things you just
can't say legally right or
images was the biggest pain in the ass
because when we were doing youtube [ __ ]
you just grab
any [ __ ] image off the internet like
right now you gotta pay for images
everything costs money we probably spent
i don't even know if i should say
probably between 50 and 100 000
on images yeah images we did that show
tournament of laughs on tbs we had a
sketch about
uh jeffrey epstein's island and they go
we can't afford epstein's island can we
do another island
i'm like no there's a picture of yeah
the picture they couldn't afford the
picture
they're like we need another island can
we make it work with another island i'm
like
no use kona yeah yeah right right
and legally it's what you can say about
people yeah so like there was like weird
things that they pushed back like i have
like
crazy jokes in it it's just absolutely
right and then like there was one joke
that was an aside it wasn't even like a
real joke right it was like
we were talking about corona and i think
the line was like uh
i think it was like uh trump with no
experiences and experienced it with
viruses outside of the ones he got from
stormy
this is not even a joke right like you
know my stuff
it's just yeah they're like you can't
say that and i go
what do you mean have you listened to
the rest right like within the first 10
seconds there's a joke about like
female genital mutilation yeah i saw
that so it's just like
why is this and then the lawyer goes i
basically say that i'm like getting a
little upset about it i'm like what's
going on
right and i go uh i go why can't we say
well there's no proof that she's had
stds and i go well she's a [ __ ]
right for a living she's a [ __ ] it's a
it's a job required
and then he goes that's why i go what he
goes
you could hurt her ability to do her job
oh wow
so it's not just saying somebody's ugly
or whatever that's fine
that's okay but her job is to [ __ ] for
money and if you say she's got an std
she might not be able to [ __ ] for money
it's an impact even though it's an
illegal job
technically yeah is it legal or i don't
think it's legal right
i think you could be a [ __ ] some places
i think in like vague
not vegas uh outside of vegas like we're
the bunny ranchers okay yeah yeah yeah
okay wow
that's so that was like i'm not gonna
fight that one like i don't care when
you do
jokes about uh the coronavirus
yeah and you do some chinese jokes do
you get yeah and people get a little
uh offended about that yeah nobody has
been offended
know what no well it's also like you're
doing a joke about the president of
china
not chinese people i literally right
this is like i literally say
in it like my thing is like is like it's
specifically sarcastic and the people
that i'm making fun of are my friends
of course you know i mean like so when i
say gently and i put
bobby lee's picture instead right right
like that's a nod to bobby
right you know what i mean right but
like this is
i hate when it's that predictable like
our whole thing was
good comedy reviews yeah useless to me
they're useless to everyone
i need outrage right right and anger and
anger
right and they literally you could tell
they didn't watch the last episode
because in the last episode i go this is
how media works
yeah bloggers right that mean nothing
get angry
right real organizations react to the
fake news story that the bloggers made
as if it's real
right then the bloggers react to the
news story and now you've created news
out of nothing
right right so we literally say it and
then and then it happens it happens it
happens immediately and all of us are
just saying like
thank you what do you think after
quarantine you're you have an
interesting eye on culture
and the way people behave nobody really
knows what's going to happen
after this ends right when we get a
vaccine when does it end is it the
vaccination
i i think by september we're totally
done yeah i think we're done in phases
and i think we're done late spring or at
least summer yeah we start to really see
it and then by september i think we're
good
okay or do people run out of their homes
and go
[ __ ] and take their computers and phones
and throw them away and go [ __ ] that
i just wanna live and jump in a lake and
[ __ ] and go to bars and do country line
dancing
do people do that or do they go i've
just
programmed now to live on this device
and i'm gonna live on it forever what do
you think
i don't know yeah i and i've said before
in the show i don't know
i i don't know but we've learned how to
live on these devices
one week of [ __ ] and then everyone's
back it's like yeah why was i doing that
right i think it's one week to just know
that you could do it it'll be a one week
to go out
hedonism yeah crazy do [ __ ] call family
members you don't even like
and then you have to see them i kind of
like that christmas is cancelled
i love it and everyone's so angry at me
but i love it
i did ten minute socially distance of
things with my parents
wave in new york drive-by
right now just calm down make an
underhanded you know i went i went i saw
my father my stepmother
i said hey how are you i said i got a
new house it's really nice my stepmother
goes
yeah but you're all alone there don't
you get lonely i'm like you got me
all right you won
you did it we can leave so but i i don't
know but you're engaged
yeah you're engaged yeah you're gonna
get married i'm gonna get ready what
made you decide this was just
the time um i got a great girl man i
wish
i i want to be like you know cynical
about it but i really got great girl man
yeah so it's just lock it up
literally yeah she's just a great girl
it's just awesome
are kids coming soon she's getting her
masters so like
i want her to do whatever she wants and
you know maybe get a job and then get
one of those
big fans she what is she into doing
um she's gonna try to work in tech i
mean that's that's the idea but like
every company's tech
you know what i mean so everything's
attached yeah exactly if it's working
for amazon
or whatever it is one of these last time
you came out a lot of people that
listened were in the creative space
like writers comics musicians i got hit
up by musicians aspiring rappers whoever
people right
yeah and many of them are dead now uh
because that's the way that's the way
this business works
it's very sad but that's the way the
business it's working out for you i mean
you you've got a pool
it's and it's good it's been good it's a
jacuzzi hey there's bigger pools
did you know people did people pronounce
it jacuzz
um or did they do jacuzzi oh interesting
no we
in in long island we said jacuzz was too
close to
the jews so we said
yeah yeah yeah they were like wait a
minute or you said i got to jakku and
they said good let's start getting them
together and try to
fix this place up a bit uh
but what are what are people doing now
that's working and what are people that
are not like if you're a young guy now
young gal yeah young non-binary person
yeah yeah and you wanna elliot
shout out to elliot page yeah and you
wanna get all the money all the money
marvel
lit all of them hey marvel but like the
straight money
well i'm co i'm coming in i wanna come
out as trans to
prove that there's a trans person they
won't [ __ ] with
because i've proven it with gay i've
proven it with gay
i've proven it with fat and gay now i'm
gonna prove it with trans
where i still they're gonna go no no no
no not him you know what's funny is like
everybody will still be like tim we
don't care yeah we don't just keep
ranting we don't care what you do with
your private time yeah
so what do you what do you think what do
you think tim's in the special by the
way did you see your passion i'm excited
what are people doing thank you for
sending it over ben sorry yeah
no thank you three times three days
after i
go damn can we get a picture of you in
the what was it
yeah yeah i don't know i'm just
wandering around like mini malls yes i
got you
yeah three days go by i go damn how's
that picture yeah i'm like this is my
guy
yeah i'm talking about couches with
housewives it's i'm i'm living in the
suburbs now it's a different world
you go to jacuzzi yeah
it's very nice you could get soft i
think you're getting soft well
i'm trying not a little bit we had
candace owens on that did
that's what you're trying to harden up
yeah you almost ran over that black kid
on the scooter
remember
yeah so what are people doing now that
you go you're looking at them and going
this is interesting this is working or
even like
in a general sense if somebody's out
there and they're going [ __ ] i love what
andrew did how do i do that what do they
do i love what you're doing
well that's very i've been you know i've
always loved you you've always been a
big fan and a supporter and
now you got it you got it man you got it
i appreciate it yeah so i love what
you're doing
here's the thing i don't know i don't
know
for what you do i don't know if it's
replicatable
does that make sense uh well like last
time i came on here i was like
people have to really destroy their
lives to be me you have to really
to really put the time in yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
but i i think you just i think you'd
like you said was it worth it like yeah
a million times no i don't want to do
any of this
i truly don't i don't want to be in the
business there are bigger pools but i
think what you're doing
isn't replicatable either because nobody
else is doing it on the level you're
doing it nobody's doing it well
yeah to be honest there's a lot of
people that had the chance
to do the funnier version of the daily
show yeah the funnier version of that
and they've not
done it how have you been able to do it
how have you been able to do it
and what does that say to other people
that might want to do it out there uh
first of all uh and i don't care if it
sounds corny i have a great team of guys
that are
like absolutely hilarious right and
they're really good so mark gagnon
co-created the show with me and he's the
co-creator on the special
right uh robbie slovick is a hilarious i
love robbie
funny he writes for the show my guy fa
ill guy he was a guy who never did come
in his life he's a
lawyer in london yeah love it and i was
just like dude you want to come and just
be part of this yeah yeah and uh he's
got the suit and his girlfriend and
that's where that joke ended up coming
from
wow and uh but yeah so these guys are
great and then alex media the guy
my ben right he directed the whole thing
but so these guys are incredible and
they're all really smart
and um we come up with these ideas
together so i can't take credit
this leads me to my next question is
comedy now
a team sport is this a team does it if
you want to do it at the level
that we're doing it and when i say we i
don't just be me i mean like you
and there are other guys that are
actually doing it at an elite level
where you're
affecting culture yeah you cannot do it
only by yourself
because i'm not you're competing with me
right and my guys
there's no way right you could do that
by yourself
yeah because i'm not i'm not talking to
you i'm talking the average comic
right i'm better than you i can't do it
either if you've seen what i
work with him and and dan carney i mean
it's a rough go
for me i mean it is very hard very
difficult
we had these comments we would be like
we had these combos where you were
talking about
you and ben and you're like yeah i have
my guy you can do this [ __ ] he's amazing
what is that yeah legit without him i'm
[ __ ]
i'm not me yeah without him literally
yeah he's amazing yeah
uh so that's very interesting so if
you're a comic now and you're coming out
obviously you get it like all these guys
they want all the credit for themselves
and it's like we're going to end up
getting the credit
yeah let people know about the squad
yeah it's just not gonna
i had i had dan dan the funny guy was
opening for me and he did really well
one night in salt lake city i
got on him the night before him i was
like i said well no i said doing the
night before i'm like i want you to go
take risks on stage yeah yeah and do
things you had like
not just joke just go out there and he
went and he murdered and as he was
murdering i said i gotta
destroy him yes so then i got up there
and i just i called people up on a stage
i mean it was just an out-of-body
experience you got to make them forget
all about him yes he doesn't exist and i
explained to him afterwards i said
that's what's great about having funny
people in your orbit yes is it's a
healthy competition
and you want to you know you watch
you push push me yeah yeah say hi with
martin i want to get marcus
very funny guy i can't be lazy you know
what i'm saying i cannot be lazy i gotta
[ __ ] go he opens up for me on the
road yeah yeah yeah
but yeah so having these guys is like
it's it we can create things that just
people can't create
and like that's the thing like how do
you find those people this is a question
a lot of people are going to ask for
competency okay so like
if you're competent you can learn
anything okay so
if so alex media learned how to edit on
premiere eight days before
the special came out wow right or before
we had to edit the special right and he
added the special yeah
and mark as well but mark had his
premiere but like he's so competent
that i'm like yeah you're gonna figure
it out so i'm only looking for
competence and then i
and i look for do you have as high
standards for the content as i do
because if you do
i can relax right if you don't
everything you put out i gotta double
check
and that's it i might as well just done
it myself yeah yeah you know so like
those are the things i'm always yeah i
think it's the same thing i look for
people that want
to like win for lack of a better word
they want to put out things that people
really resonate with yes and they go
this is and and then
and sometimes you gotta you're sometimes
they think that like
you know it's hard to
it not that it's hard but i feel like
it's it's a challenge
not always working alone because we're
used to as stand-ups we're used to like
like we're just we're it's just us yeah
and we go out there we work on our jokes
we go out and do this thing but when you
have other people you have a team of
people
there's a give and take push and pull
there's it's a different challenge
and and you can make something greater
you can make something great what human
beings have done right yeah it's like we
sacrifice a little bit of ourselves for
the greater good
how you make the pyramids do you ever
get in disagreements where you go like
i'm going to i'm going to let mark win
this one because i trust him the best
idea wins
yeah best idea was no i like that i have
no ego no we go best i
look like i have a lot of ego yeah when
it comes to
the content the best idea wins and
everybody knows it that's the thing
about you a lot of people look at you
and go you have a lot of ego and that's
only because of what you say and do yes
100 percent yeah yeah
the way you present yourself that's the
only reason people would ever think that
but but actually here's what's smart
about you
you're humble they're a bigger pool
i'm dying i'm dying for christmas tree
but that's how tall trees get
freeze come on this is nature it's a
horror
my life is a heart no i'm very listen
i'm lucky
and i've done well horror story
i'm lucky and things have been good but
it's also it was a long stretch of not
good
so yeah but it's best idea wins you the
thing about you is you surround yourself
with very smart people yep you take
advice
you ask people like that and that's what
makes people very successful
yeah is this the funniest thing is this
hey this is my pitch for the joke
yeah and then i got to make everybody in
the room that i'm paying
feel comfortable enough to tell me it's
not
funny right right right and then so that
is the initial period that everybody
gets there
yeah obviously no we're not like
trashing ideas of jokes we're always
like how can we build that like
right somebody will come up with like
all right well what can we do that's
kind of connecting tom hanks in this way
right and then oh what if we did that
and right okay
i think the woody joke came around like
that you know
okay tom hanks they're calling him a
pedophile it's so dense with jokes
like it has a lot of jokes so so that's
yeah and i haven't said this on any pot
i'll save it here okay for here but like
the first time i think i i was going
okay how can i do comedy in a way where
i can compete with these big [ __ ]
streaming things but i gotta get it to
the people so i'm like
okay i can utilize the internet and like
if you don't trust me maybe i'll give
you smaller versions etc
so we figured that out how the average
comic that's funny can put their stuff
up and start to like put together a
career right and like
we got that this time the thing that
i've always thought about comedy that
was so
shitty is this shelf life it's like a
magic trick that you
tell how you do the trick afterwards
right so if you tell the same
if you tell the joke we're not talking
about impressionists right we're just
talking about like punch lines whatever
if i tell you that joke once the next
time i tell it to you
you're like yeah least funny thing right
right like it's not funny you've loaded
it with so many jokes people can watch
it again and again and
pull new things out of it every time so
that's what i was like how do i increase
the shelf life
and load it with so many jokes and the
pictures
punch the jokes right so now i'm not
doing what these [ __ ] idiots on late
night do i can't believe
that they thought that this was okay to
tell jokes and wait for a punch line
when nobody's there
right wait for the laugh kitchen table
it's absurd
yeah it makes you feel so uncomfortable
at home i feel very strange
but that shows you how detached they are
to like actually like connecting
i think this quarantine one of the
things it's done is it's taking them out
of the theaters and taking them out of
makeup and taking the writers
and you're you're kind of like well i'm
sure the writers are still there but
like
you see them unmasked for lack of a
better word and you go oh my god you
suck you suck you suck you're not good
yeah
i should be famous like people on the
couch go i can be ellen i can be not
funny too
right yeah wow yeah that's what he was
like let's make it so joke dance we're
not gonna
we're not gonna sit and like bask in our
laughs we're literally just gonna the
second a joke is finished another one
comes right
and then the images are gonna punch the
jokes so you know exactly like there's
we measure those images like when we say
it when i say
align the image is coming out on a
specific line
right it takes hours to line those
images up and then what we do is we hide
all these things in the images
so when you watch the special and you
look at me and you kind of look at
images you see one thing
if you watch the special and only look
at the images it's a different special
wow so you have you have like also
sensory
differences two different specials yeah
happening they're happening at the same
time yeah so then people start listening
to it and it has this almost like rap
effect where you're like oh i didn't
notice
jay-z said that line right or something
people are going back and forth on
twitter with you and it's like
interactive
without being hokey exactly
but let's do we have like these little
lines in there like i
i want to do something where we can sit
down and like go over
like we have this one line it's we're
talking about the amy cooper yeah
and uh uh instead of saying you probably
haven't heard about her up until now
yeah we say you probably haven't heard
about her emmett till now
yeah yeah jesus yeah right and it's
quick it's quick and then the next line
is
so i'll jog your memory and the picture
is ahmad arbory
yeah and it's like flashing it's like
these things are going so fast
it's very racially triggering in very
different ways
like it's that is what you just
described so it's like the people that
kept us
about it that's a nightmare for like a
freshman at columbia university
what you just described it's like emmett
till arbor you're like oh my god
they're like short circuiting they're
falling on a dorm room floor yeah but if
you've got about asian jokes it's like
do you just not care about any other
group of people they don't everybody got
made fun of yeah everybody got what
like i said i look like a [ __ ] banker
from gringotts right the hair like i'm
trashing me yeah everybody's everybody
gets it so it's like don't put yourself
on a pedestal what is what do you want
to do
when quarantine ends and when you can go
back out are you like let's go all over
the world
i still got the stand-up special yeah i
want to put out you want to put out so i
just
didn't film it we got shut down by that
so i want to do that and then um
i want to get back to doing these but
just like shorter we'll do that you know
on youtube
yeah and then because i want to go like
i want to go i realized like
i want to go and i lean to my age and
say i want to see the world a little bit
yeah yeah
when this whole thing happened yeah i'm
like you know i've been to cleveland
four times
i've been to cleveland and listen love
hilarities love everyone there i got the
engraved bat thank you
uh i want to go to amsterdam all of that
yeah
i want to see europe and the uk and
brussels and ireland and like
i want to do comedy everywhere that i
can when everything was shutting down i
was like
[ __ ] yeah i really missed my chance i
wanted to be in australia and obviously
the world's going to open up again but
you you kind of gained so much effort
yeah i gained a lot now when you go over
there it's worth it tickets will sell
exactly it'll be worth it before when
you would go over there it would be like
oh i got a few friends in brussels
i've done that tour in europe like some
people know you right and then i did a
tour in europe where
a lot of people knew me it's different
and the second one is so much much
better
yeah so much better yeah and then that's
what you'll have now
yeah and then yeah it's [ __ ] sick you
just travel europe you're just eating
this delicious food
yeah it's great everything's fun it's
just fun yeah that's that's what i'm i'm
hoping for i've been eating good by the
way yeah yeah
you've been noticing i've been seeing
what your girl no [ __ ]
my girl cooks even though she's nice the
restaurants that she picks up oh yeah
she does great restaurants she's
she's like you she's like great she
knows march she gets it we should all
have a little
let's do it we'll go absolutely yeah
we'll go out to bernie
baby i love it first time i went there
my dad took me when i was seven
okay yeah my gosh you hate it seven
years old
seven years old seventh grade okay so
seventh grade i went because i wanted to
go i was
explaining what it is it's the best it's
the it's really the best
probably seafood restaurant in the world
yeah i would say so okay it's the top
two to three restaurants in new york
city top five to ten in america
you know conservatively speaking um
a a a uh just palace
you know of of seafood and the the way
they prepare the food and everything's
executed
incredibly well and and uh eric repair
and the maguila cos rip who died
uh the the vision of that restaurant was
to make this glittering seafood palace
in new york city
that would rival the the greatest
restaurants of of paris and and
and it did successful successfully yeah
truly amazing and i went there at
seventh grade and
and and this is my big date to celebrate
nothing yeah my girlfriend oh and
yeah i went there when i was popping
pimples off my back yeah yeah no it was
it was it was amazing
it was amazing and then i just realized
schultz yeah
i realized that like you know after that
you look at
you look at other things and you go ever
it's great
to listen here's the thing it's great to
drive in a rolls-royce
yeah you don't have to own one but it's
great to drive into a rolls-royce test
just know and you know why know why it's
rolls-royce
that's the reality know why it's rules
right and that's and
my friends jeffrey and just lane would
say these things too you have to drive
rolls-royce and i don't know what they
were talking about but they said yeah i
have to drive it
it's very odd but they kept bringing
that up rolls royce i don't know but no
but
la bernadine is that russia where you go
tweet then you know what everything else
is
you go oh i get it yeah yeah yeah i get
it and it just
it it it puts things in an order yeah
and it orders things for you yeah
in a way it's like a great athlete or
even a great comic like yeah
patrice o'neil but you're just like oh
that is the best you watch elephant in
the room and you get it you go okay now
i can put everything together and i can
organize these things in my head because
i've seen this really amazing thing
that is so rare yeah yeah and and will
never happen again in the configuration
it is right
they'll never be another patrice they'll
never be another bernadette they'll be
great restaurants right right but
that set of circumstances that made that
restaurant what it was
the location the this or that it's all
there and that's
what i i love about going out to eat in
really nice places is that
you know that eventually i went to
luger's the other day and i went
it's over bro it's over it's over it's
over there
it is it's over for my birthday with my
folks yes it's over
they're broken they're broken broken by
that new york times no one's there
it's like but you know what it is it's
okay because
it would be weirder if it wasn't over
because it would open in 1863
it's like it's supposed to stop it's
supposed to stay
too long there's too much there's got to
be a new era of
restaurants of of of of restaurant tours
of chefs of people
that keep reinventing and reimagining
things to make them better yeah it's
like comedy it's like news yeah
media it's like everything there you
have to shed this now you look you said
something very interesting once i want
to talk to you about this about youtube
okay yeah you said comics are some of
the funniest people in the world but
they don't utilize social media
effectively and they don't
yeah and then you look at a lot of
youtubers i'm friends with youtubers out
here in california they're nice people
but their content is fundamentally
different from comics right
fundamentally different it's more like
hey this is my day in the life
whatever it is some of them are funny
but their job is not to be funny the job
should be relatable or to be accessible
whatever it is right aspirational
aspirational a lot of them the life is
aspirational oh that would be cool to
drive in that car
to go to these places how does a comic
yeah whose job is to be very
funny yeah kind of get into this world
of youtube where it's like we can't do
those things or we
we would have to be funny we have to be
funny yeah we are fun we can be funny
because it's it's it is an interesting
divide right because you do look at
some of the stuff on there and you go
this is some of this content's
interesting some of it's you know i
don't even know what it is
some of it truly i don't know what it is
i'm not watching mukbang somebody's just
brushing their teeth for three hours
it's got 10 million views i think
society's in trouble yeah
um but what is it about comedians that
they
in those environments don't catch on i
think that
two things happen one we get a false
sense of validation from being on stage
that's true they don't have the stage so
they
need the views that's
right right they can't go up in front of
30 people at the village lantern and do
decently and be like i'm funny
i did it i did it i did it they need to
put out the video and then by putting
out the video if it's good
so many more people see it like think
about how many more people listen to
this podcast than see you at a comedy
club in texas so you can't even
fathom but you could get hundreds of
thousands of views that you're getting
right now and that's right
but when we go sell out a theater we
think we made it
right like how crazy are we when we're
thinking there's so much
well half a million people see something
listen to something we do
two thousand people come to us what we
what we do in the in that space
is um is is unique right because
it's it's kind of what the same reason
that the restaurants are great or what i
it's it's it's it's an audience yes and
you you you appreciate all that yes
this hundred percent not to do also i
want to say something we do but you're
right
long term you got to reach more people
than who come out to have that truly
unique experience
what we're doing yeah but i totally
understand the connection between
chef and comic now yes yeah it is the
closest that i've seen yes in the
creative field i believe i agree with
you in comic people oh it's like boxing
i use the box it's nothing like boxing
right
but chef right yes yes and i've watched
those shows that everybody's watching on
netflix whatever but even going through
like
the experience they go through almost
like the borderline psychosis
yeah so like trying to take things that
are like mundane and make them
interesting like
that's literally what we do right and
then having to sit there and watch
people consume
and they have to curate an experience
it's a diner for the whole thing from
when they walk into that restaurant when
they leave yeah yeah every course of
food the service what it looks like
they have to curate that experience
that's that to me i've always seen that
overlap
but to me i'm almost like like i want my
show to be that way at the theater of
the club like
i wanted to start when you walk in the
door right not when i go on stage and
say hello
when you walk in the door there should
be something there should be a music
there should be something visual the
show begins when you walk in it sets a
tone yeah right like okay if we go to
the bernadine or whatever
you walk out the [ __ ] somalia is
walking around with the the the pimp cup
chains right
right and yeah and you're just like what
the [ __ ] is going on i i didn't know
anything like that i don't know anything
about these places my girl knows this
[ __ ] i asked the [ __ ] lady i was like
what are you like what's up with the
chain
yeah and uh i thought that she was like
the head waitress
right do you know i thought like you
know she was like
that was like yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's a test of in or whatever i think is
the term
uh taste of wine yeah yeah something
like that yes yes and i guess
it's just an ancient thing to have a
little what are we doing when we
get back into stand up like yeah what
are we doing for our shows like
enough uh you know when
you know because everyone's used to
seeing us do all these other things
you're on netflix with a podcast are we
going to have to beef up our live shows
to make them
it's totally different yeah i want to be
a carnival me too
like i i agree with you and yeah you
would actually fit this perfectly
right because it's like i want to have
the hour that we put
that that we put out we put together and
yeah i don't care if it's done in a tiny
little comedy club or a big theater
whatever it is and that was but when i
go
tour tour yeah and we're doing [ __ ]
theaters and arenas
yeah i want this to be a carnival right
i want there to be stand-up i want us
all to be [ __ ] singing
yeah i want i want it to be a wild
experience yes yes
because the reality is is like one of
the reasons why i've been so successful
on the road is because i create these
unique experiences
through interacting with the crowd right
yeah so like when you come there you
know
that's never going to happen again yeah
so you're like i can't miss
what that's what i try to do with that
you brought the people up on the stage
yeah that's what i'm trying to everybody
there is telling their friends i don't
know what was happening he's got people
i want people to come to the show and
experience an act of domestic terrorism
you know i want the fbi to look at what
constitutes a terrorist group and say
does this does this fit that
but i i think it's not enough anymore to
just
do stand up i think it is enough but i
think
going forward like people are going to
want all kinds of different [ __ ]
i think that because it's that element
of uncertainty yes because they walk in
they know you're going to do funny stuff
it's going to be funny
but i think that crowd interaction or
crowd work or riffing or any of that
and then you add other people into it
you add other things that's what people
may want
because people that are going to go out
they go i want a [ __ ] concert i want
a [ __ ]
really insane night i want something to
tell people about
yeah i want to have that experience it's
like the [ __ ] restaurant you could go
have the dover soul right or you could
have dover soul
and then cut it with a fish knife right
i don't know what a fish knife
is right but you want sharp yeah right
but i got this specific knife and
they're like oh yeah
oh yeah because it's so soft that you
don't need to saw through it
yeah it's a little trick day and now i'm
telling you about it let me ask you a
controversial question yes
should comics be doing like 10 specials
or is it time to hang it up
is it time what's going on i don't want
to do a special unless i have to talk
about something
right right do you know what i'm saying
like yeah i mean there's uh so many
comics have been around forever since
we're two yeah
is it time for any of them to leave and
this is one of my
this is one of the things i say and i
want the tim dil do i want to do the tim
dylan show answer
or do i is it the real answer it's the
real answer the real answer is
keep on doing until the wheels fall off
it makes you happy the tim dillon show
answers
a lot of guys got to go
i love you but you gotta go you gotta go
and i respect you and you've done it but
what are we still
doing at a certain point right
at a certain point you've done it like
how much can you do it like it's you
know
yeah what do you see yeah i mean i get
it if it makes you happy do whatever
makes you happy
what if we doesn't do what makes me
happy and what makes me happy is you
not doing this anymore they have to go
yes or yes
yeah they gotta go man i love you i
think yeah yes or yes
we should do a yearly purge yeah of them
yeah
we just sit down it has to happen and we
just instead of like the time what is
gonna happen to comedy clubs in this
in in this i think comedy clubs are good
because i think that's
i think comic clubs are going to be good
they'll be good i think they can hang on
because it's just a hard
yeah economic thing a lot of them will
hang out yeah for whatever reason i
think a lot of them will but i think
they're good and i think that will be
one of the first experiences that people
go back out in public to do
yeah it's kind of safe you're not making
out with strangers on a dance floor
right
you're you are already somewhat distant
guys you're with your friends you're
laughing and you're kind of like
somebody's regaling the times and you
want to relate to it i think right i
think they'll thrive
100 the comedy clubs is where we'll be
working on our bits and then have these
kind of intimate experiences
but when it comes to creating a show
yeah
the reality is if i'm doing the garden
yeah and i'm making fun of someone in
the front row
nobody else in the garden can see that
person in the front right so i have to
change my show to accommodate
that venue the venue right experience
you can't
even doing the the monologue what we're
doing is like i have to constantly
change what i'm doing like right early
in my career i'm just doing material i
put out two special materials
right okay i got really good at that and
i'm not trying to pat myself in the
background i was really good at it right
what am i not really good at how better
let's get better yeah okay i see these
guys doing monologues all the time
never once have i thought they're funny
right and i'm just like how has nobody
tried to do this funny yet
right they suck right okay maybe i could
i'm terrified
of looking like an idiot right terrified
good i should go do that thing i'm
terrified of
we start doing it and then why don't
people do more [ __ ] that scares them
why do you think i don't know i mean i i
i would say that you it's painful yeah
but you will do it
why will you do it i mean i'm a little
crazy you're a little crazy but you also
don't have shame
i want i don't have shame you won't
[ __ ] fail i'll fail
i'll fail i'll fail why won't i pay
putty on yeah i'll fail
why would i have a what i had that
hoodie that bay pudding
give me that hoodie give me that little
fail no it's just
this hoodie that i that everyone makes
fun of me for because i did a sketch
with it on
but when i put this hoodie on i become a
different person people don't understand
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] about
politics anymore when i put this hoodie
on i don't care
about [ __ ] oh do you read a book what
book you read you want to [ __ ]
yo what do you think is gonna happen no
no yeah when i put this hoodie on i
realize
that i am beautiful you are gorgeous and
that yeah because the black man came up
to me and he said you look fresh as [ __ ]
when i had this on yeah and no one had
ever been complimentary to me like that
before
and i've discovered that i can be a new
person with just one garment of clothing
yeah
and i could maybe start smoking weed
again and doing pills and drinking that
coffee
that person doesn't have a drug problem
the person in this
is responsible he can no but i
i you know mike lawrence said something
really good once somebody said i'm
afraid to do this show and mike lawrence
goes are you too good to fail
i've never felt like i was too good to
fail yeah i think that's part of why i
do [ __ ]
i don't feel like i'm too good to fail
yeah i don't feel like i'm too if i put
out a
[ __ ] video and it gets a few thousand
views that's okay
a lot of comics don't want to start
pursuing [ __ ] online because they're
like what am i gonna have to build this
[ __ ]
social media network yeah you do in the
beginning yeah you do you have to do it
yeah and keep doing it yeah and it is
what it is in the beginning
we i had no followers i had nothing you
know but i i don't feel like too good to
i feel like i got
as long as i'm playing i'm okay if i'm
on the field i'm okay
if i'm on the bench pointing at people
on the field going [ __ ] them
loser that's where i get depressed
yeah i gotta play yeah and if that's the
way that i i feel good about myself
decent about myself not tremendous but
there's a guy i grew up with siddiqui
thomas right yes jamaican dude
yeah hilarious he would hit on every
girl
right he would he would his rate of like
closing was probably like
2 out of 10 or 3 out of ten right which
is good okay
it's good yeah i didn't think he was a
loser when he failed
right i thought he was the bravest
[ __ ] i've ever seen
because when i was young i was terrified
right of not only getting rejected but
my friends seeing me get rejected
right and then then i thought in my mind
i was like i'm gonna lose some sort of
social currency to my friends
they think i'm cool the bravest thing
anyone can do right now literally to me
yeah is talk to a woman to
sit down and speak to a woman and listen
to them
and take their opinion seriously is to
me
braver than jumping out of a plane
without a parachute
in my life like for me to have to do
that
is huge so that's a big no no upside for
you
very little upside down well whitney
company gave us that table in the back
which we paid her for
she keeps acting like it's charity i'm
like dude we just gave you money
it sounds enough yeah but i love her i
love whitney
because whitney is a power you know
she's a real [ __ ]
she's a great comic and she's a great
comic great unstoppable force
unstoppable force she will get it done
she'll get it she's not afraid as well
she thinks she's afraid
right but that is what pushes her does
that make sense how do you
when you see people that
do you believe that hard work is genetic
george carlin said maybe it is genetic
there's something very interesting about
that yeah i know people who i look at or
uh yeah
what is it um nature versus nurture i
think it's
it's nurture but i think you have to see
hard work at a very young age
to get it to and then that's like i saw
my mom getting up every day yeah
coaching a swim team getting up at 5am
doing everything uh
i i get it i also saw my dad who i love
like
you know was a really great musician but
never took it to the level he could have
yeah i so i
had both of those experiences right why
were you afraid of repeating what your
dad
oh yeah i was afraid of having a studio
in my house in the suburbs yeah
uh wait like my dad oh no
my dad had a studio or he would just sit
in a room in his house in the suburbs
but no one cared he was just playing his
guitar okay
that's way different totally different i
have one father yeah and
um he but no i was afraid of and my dad
was a really talented guy and he was
talented because i knew that because
other people tell me he wouldn't
like other people would say your dad at
this massive band on long island the 70s
was really big
did you know about that i'm like kinda
and my dad didn't really keep a lot of
that stuff around right there was no
like photos of it
so i was like oh okay catholic thing
like uh no just didn't
i think he didn't want to remind himself
that he was on this track that never
panned
out yeah it's hard yeah it's tough right
and i get it he had a kid either well
you gotta
you know got a sales job or whatever but
i when i got into this i was 25 years
old and i'm like
this is my the last thing that i have
the shot to be good at
there's not a lot of things you can do
at 25 right i mean
there's some certainly but a lot this is
the other thing about life that people
don't really want to
talk about which is like you know at a
certain point you gotta you gotta
make uh uh a decision and stick with it
you don't ha you can't reinvent yourself
over 40 years what point i don't know i
don't think it's 25
no i think it'll be later i think i
don't think it's a specific age okay
i think that it's a it's a it's a moment
and i don't think i don't think you can
uh reinvent everything you want like i
know people that have wanted to be ten
things yeah and i'm like well this is a
problem yeah every three years you want
to be another thing
and you know what i notice about those
people the each one of those things
has one thing in common right and
they're just
lily padding to the next thing because
that one isn't working and it's usually
validation i look at yes it's like i
want people to like me okay i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be an actress it doesn't work
i'm going to be a pilates coach
that's on youtube uh it's not really i
look at people that are really funny and
i say to myself
i look at people that are really funny
and haven't made a
haven't made much of their careers and i
and i and i and i think a lot of that is
because they
they don't get bored easily i get very
bored
who is that i look at comics that are
very funny that haven't
built a fan base that's a lot of people
right
is it no that's the thing like there's
really there's
i don't want to be insulting but there's
there are guys that we know this should
be bigger i can
and i would be bigger is yes and i think
but they have drug issues
usually people that that are no yeah i
don't know i don't know if they do
there's different levels of funny right
like like if we're just being honest
let's be honest
there is a lot of young comics you're
gonna listen to this they should and
they should [ __ ] pay
extra close attention because they're
not the elite level funny yet yes and
you and i were about young comics i mean
bill burns no i'm kidding
i just i'm just
i'm kidding but uh like you and i were
both at the
at the point where we're not funny right
and then we start to get to the point
where we're funny
right but we're not elite funny yet yes
and then we get to the point where
you want to get to elite funny right and
people are elite funny
it's so hard to get to now it's hard to
get to but they are making a living
even if they're [ __ ] drug addicts
they're making a living yeah
if they're drug addicts they're not as
famous as they should be
but they're still living they're living
that's how
yeah few people are elite right that's a
great point there's so this this is such
a small group of people
it gets whittled down it constantly gets
whittled down there's a hand it was a
handful of people there's really a
handful of us
like when you think about it so it's
like there's a lot of people in the
middle and they're like why don't i have
a career it's like well that's not how
it works
yeah this [ __ ] is too fun for everybody
to do it yeah so if you want to have the
career career you have to be elite right
you have don't you think there's a value
in the fact that people like you
and i think people like me get bored
which [ __ ] easily we get bored
and we go i want to do cool [ __ ] and new
[ __ ] i can tell you exactly why i love
stand up
yeah because it is
the basketball hoop changing height
every single time you go on the court
right so you practice your free throws
on a ten foot
yeah right you're like i got that down
right and then you go up
at hilarity's and clean there's a way
that we can use a white sport
yes just for my yes is the ten the
tennis
i got it right okay okay ready yes here
we go i'm ready
tennis yes every time you go onto the
court
you have a different size racket wow yes
now you're with me
yes so now you're like i perfected it
with that one racket
but i met hilarity's and it's this tiny
little racket and now when i try to
serve it doesn't do the whole
so i got to figure out i got to figure
out how to be so good at this no matter
what size
racket i have yeah it's i'm gonna be
successful and that's gonna take
you [ __ ] decades so people like you
and i that can get bored of [ __ ] that we
can get good at quickly
right we're gonna go okay okay i'm
moving i know some of these young guys
who say things like i just want a good
quality of life
kill yourself right yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love that yeah
why are we yeah yeah why would you tell
me that why would you tell me that
i want to conquer the world right right
but it's true
if you're using those words and you're
in your 20s you're you're in trouble
i mean like you're in [ __ ] trouble i
tell people you will go no further than
your dream
right with this business right right
right no further so if you just want to
make a living
that is if you're lucky right you'll get
there if you're lucky
right if you say i want to sell out
arenas
you might get to theaters yeah and
that's pretty [ __ ] that's pretty cool
right yeah but you gotta go like dreams
cost nothing
yeah this will just [ __ ] dream yeah i
want to make a living to me you quit
already
right you quit i said that i wanted to
get killed by the cia but i may settle
for
i may settle for half a million youtube
subscribers
heyo um
when trump is gone yeah when he leaves
does he leave
or is he still like obviously he'll
leave but like is he still gonna be a
force does he just go play
off what do you think he does does he
keep doing the rallies i'm curious it's
hard he's he's the biggest star
he is so talented he's so talented what
is that called that's not stand-up but
what i don't know what it is
it doesn't have a name but is it like
are you emceeing
like what is that skill that he's he's
off the top he's riffing he's
he's in the moment he's with his people
he's just leading that cult like
does he keep doing that does he if it's
that easy
how could you not imagine standing i
know it was that easy was that easy
like he's literally doing what every
stand-up
wishes stand stand-up was yeah which is
i'll go up there just be me
i'll be i just talk you guys go crazy
yeah i don't have to think of these like
brilliant clever like
switches and premises that are genius
literally just say what are the words
you guys wanted me to say
right lock her up yeah it goes crazy so
it's like
how could you not do that right the
question is
his age don't you think his age it plays
a little
it's high he's up there if he's 64. this
guy's gonna be a nuisance yeah but he's
in his 70s late set yeah it's getting
there do you want to do that do you want
to be on adderall at a certain point you
have to
you have to you have to close it up yeah
just for like life value like
right do you really want to like go
through it right tweet all [ __ ] day i
think that he says no right
now if he's that much of a maniac which
all them are that he's really thinking
he's going to run again
right then he's got to stay in
i think he's just fronting like he's
going to do it because he wants to have
enough
political leverage to get [ __ ] he wants
yeah probably right right
yeah i don't think he's gonna he wants
to run again i know somebody talks to
him he does think he's running again
he's not right that's he's not running
again but now do you think they're gonna
lock him
up no i i agree they won't they don't
want to tear the country apart
don't even tell the country it looks bad
you can't lock up presidents
it's just it's a bad bad look for
everyone in the world yeah just let it
go
exactly you let it go everything's cool
it's like always a crook it's like
that's why people like him
yeah you've identified why people like
it you identify why he has a family
yeah yeah yeah it's like brooks yeah
it's not a crook
right it's true who's not a crook
but that's the thing like if we were
crooks we wouldn't be in entertainment
no we'd be in politics yeah it's true
like if you actually
care about the world at all i'm not
saying we're actually a [ __ ] change
in the world like i'm not like
doing this like you know narcissistic
approach to
content right but like i think that we
have
way more sway on the average person's
thinking than a politician
like what the [ __ ] do they ever do they
just they do nothing nothing
so the last time you were on rogue or
not the last time but a few times ago
you said netflix going out of business
yes and now you have a show on netflix
yeah do you have any more predictions
i'm a politician baby
do you have any more predictions that
might come true like do you want to can
i just
do that amazon prime's going out of
business and in two years from now
you're uh uh
like could i be honest you have a huge
deal you know more than most people yeah
what is it fake business is your shirt
right fake business i didn't understand
yeah modern capitalism right right i i l
i was approaching netflix right
like most businesses where in order to
stay around you have to produce a profit
no it's fake i didn't realize this we're
in the arab fake business
so so yeah when i say that i'm not just
going out there like
i joke around on the podcast like the 48
laws of power you got to stir up water
to catch fish yeah
yeah this is all part of my my grandpa
yeah no it wasn't i literally was going
okay if they haven't declared themselves
that they're you know profiting
off their business and they're about to
lose the most watched shows
then it's a problem how the [ __ ] are you
going to stay in business yeah but
right and then i found out oh it's a
stock
it's a stock as long as the stock price
is high yeah you don't it's the same
thing with amazon they don't even make
any money
sirius xm spotify a lot of these major
media operations are stock skills so
when i find out that it's
fake business it's just then you do some
money
it's not a big deal yeah it's not a big
deal that's just what it
that's just what it comes down to all
seriousness i was like when i found it
that that's how these things work and
that's how uber works and that's how
a lot of these like tech based companies
work i i was like oh i have to start
thinking about okay this is this is very
different like when it goes public
public is just a way that the initial
investors get to cast that cash out it's
quite fascinating how it works yeah like
going the whole idea of the stock market
was
raising money right right now the
fundraising happens
first right that's the sorry that's the
initial stock market if you will
yes then they cash out on the [ __ ]
dummies that go buy it on the stock
market and then whatever happens to the
company they don't give a flying [ __ ]
it's the era of uh it's smoke you know
yeah
that's exactly what it is once i
realized that i was like okay this is
the game
there are so many people that value uh
a streaming platform more than they
value youtube and social media
right you and i are entrenched in
youtube and social media right
yeah so we value content
i don't care what screen it's on right
i realized how valuable a name brand is
to some people
when i announced the netflix thing and i
had family members message me and they
were like uh congratulations on netflix
and your engagement
and i was like you didn't do those two
things in the same sense
it's like you knew i was engaged for a
while yeah
but that wasn't big enough and the
engagement yeah then netflix happened
they were like okay i think i should do
a little double congratulations netflix
is
is become a part of our vocabulary it's
become a
a part of everything netflix and chill
all that so for me i just want to
i want to create stuff for the most
people the people have always been my
salvation so it's like
right i want to be in front of the most
people possible and if there's more
people over there
that i haven't touched it and i think
they could really be interested in the
content we're making
i want to yeah i wanna do that of course
and honestly
i i gotta give credit where it's due
these [ __ ]
were cool with the content i thought it
was cool yeah
i thought it was gonna be fun they just
let me put out whatever yeah like
they were and i'm not saying my
experience is going to be the average
comics experience like i came in with a
lot of
equity and it wasn't something i really
like needed
but they were super supportive they we
went over budget
they stepped in yeah like
i feel like when execs do the right
thing you gotta say
complimentary [ __ ] like the executive
let ricky gervais do that
golden globes speech it's like i don't
know who that is but we gotta
congratulate him because he's
that person his [ __ ] is on the line too
and also netflix let kevin spacey direct
the whole thing which is
basically directed the whole thing your
whole show he's unbelievable
amazing and he is let me tell you
something about kevin and his lap
the guy will sit you down yeah and and
and he'll
start just petting you dude and like you
you'll feel insecure
and he'll just pet you back into having
that self-esteem that you need to save
america you know what i mean
maybe mark shout out to kevin dude for
real yeah kevin's great i'll tell you
this
it is it's crazy to watch how much
you've done in the span of time you've
done it because it's not i mean you've
been to a comedy a long time
but you've you've been able to do a lot
of really cool things in
in a span of years yeah and it's like
you're
right it's not rushing but like you are
you're running at a pace
of somebody who wants to really have a
lot of things
more so than just a comic right do you
ever see yourself down the road
with a platform with a network with
a uh whatever it is because you're
running at the pace of somebody that
wants
more than ju and it's it's a compliment
it's yeah you seem to want more than
just
i'm a great comedian do you you you like
helping people you like prov you know
is there a version of andrew schultz
down the road that
has something that's bigger than just
his own career that has kind of a
movement of culture or whatever
i bigger than career sure but not
necessarily like a platform like
i i got i'm going to do a film one of
these days yeah i really want to create
that and i want it to be like
i want to kind of create this like rat
pack vibe yeah what i mean like i think
that's what podcasts are in a lot of
ways yeah like
we watched those movies like the oceans
elevens movies yeah absolutely we're
just watching
characters hanging out that's a podcast
that's exactly what it is and like this
is a pocket like absolutely like we're
just hanging right yeah like
if we can for me what i would love to do
is create that environment and then
insert
all of us into that environment as a
film and then do that every couple years
like i think what i'll eventually do in
my career is do less projects but just
kind of bigger projects
okay and then like everybody in that
world
i want them to be you know millionaires
again it really is like it used to be
every man for himself it feels a lot
less like that now
that's the worst model the model is a
team model
people helping each other out not
relying as much on
uh people in the industry although when
you can collaborate and work with people
that support you that's great build up
enough equity so that you're doing
the show you want to do with them right
and you need to build the equity up
because
why would they take a risk why would
they go out there and take a risk
on you if you haven't proved it works
right dude i mean like
chappelle you know god bless his soul
he's whining about the deal that he got
from
comedy central it's like the guy didn't
have a hit
before that show right why would you get
it's also why would you
pull why would you pull a d why would
you pull a show off
platforms where like people that just
poor people want to watch your show they
love your show yeah the whole thing is
wow yeah but but it's like i mean as a
creator
i support him getting all the rights in
whatever way he do get it the way he's
going about it is his corner to me but
he's like yeah i got to feel bad that
you were bullied like well we have them
get them out dave shipping come on come
on out um
but it's like yeah so it's just like i
don't know i want to i want to
create that [ __ ] i want us to just i
just want us to run things i want to
create really cool projects and i want
to have enough equity to like do the
comedy that we want to do that the
majority of people like and it's not you
know infiltrated by [ __ ]
the bloggers or whatever like that like
i don't want right you know i don't want
to deal with that no one cares i mean no
one cares
no i don't care yeah i don't care i'd be
upset if there weren't
yeah yeah yeah if you're not talking
about me i'm irrelevant
yeah so i need you to say bad things so
that people watch it
yeah yeah imagine watching the thing
that people go it is a
it is just so much fun or you know what
it is the worst the worst
i think the worst uh thing you can say
about anything is what was that again
right you know what i mean nobody knows
what it is when does new york
find a couple of questions here about
new york cause you're such a new york
guy do you ever leave new york and when
do you think it comes back
i think and i'm you know me i'm very
bullish on new york
right but like i was too and then i left
i know and you have this like
insane life here and don't get me wrong
i come to your home yeah
and i i go this is nice
yeah you know like my girl i was telling
you lives up in santa barbara yeah we're
not shooting
her family's from santa barbara and i've
seen like the way that they live and
it's just like yeah
dude i'd love to wake up and have a view
of the water yeah all these things like
right
i mean this is [ __ ] life yeah um and
when comedy clubs and [ __ ] are shut down
you start going like
i could do that right right so i'm i'm
not against that but i
i am in new york my studio's in new york
my guys are in new york
and it's like i don't at this point i'm
not ready to have the conversation where
i forced them to make a decision where
they were no of course and you know when
i came to la i was really worried about
i i just figure for whatever reason i've
adjusted here i and i don't think la's
at the spot really anymore and like it
might be i hope it is i'm here for
another year we'll see
yeah i don't know where the spots could
have been that's where the talent is
it's where the talent is if we want to
move to tallahassee that's the thing
right
i really agree i agree with you so it's
just like yeah we're we're the gravity
yeah and we're going to make cool [ __ ]
yeah and like who knows what happens
with stand up who knows i think what
you're doing right now is just like
that's what i'm telling my girl i'm like
yo let's rent a place literally what
you've done
you're like what like two months ahead
of me like yeah it's an
insane place not even two months or a
month ahead of me like rent an insane
place yeah that's
it's expensive it's not that's what you
should aspire to have a place like this
yeah
yeah create you're there for a year we
don't know what the world looks like in
a year
if everything snaps back you're like i'm
in la baby and i got my great place
yeah if it doesn't you're like okay
maybe i moved to someplace that has the
perfect environment that i want to
create
the other thing i'm i'm here for a year
it's uh and the reason that we got we
got the house is we can put a stew we
want to put a really cool studio
here and we put a cool studio in yeah
and and and uh
and i want to do other things uh we're
doing other types of shows we're gonna
do stuff with social media people which
could be interesting right
because i'm outside of that world a
little bit we're going to start doing
stuff with
people that i wouldn't work with
necessarily you should
but i should yeah why not and and we're
going to figure all that out
and i think that it's going to be like
it's an adventure
there are so few certainties
right now yeah everything is up in the
air but that's kind of where
guys like us thrive yeah that's why i i
don't mind it i don't mind it i
i actually like it i don't mind it um
final question
yeah i just want to say like i knew
we were going to win the pandemic yeah i
knew this well i appreciate it but i
knew this
yes at the beginning yeah i knew this
yeah i would not be surprised if we
didn't have text message conversations
about this we're probably dead
it's just and what does two sociopaths
just going we're going to win the
pandemic yeah like the
the news being like there's another
mobile movement 100 000 people
like we're going to win this and i'm
like i agree that's you that video is
popping yeah yeah
it sounds crazy but at the same time
like
when there's chaos yeah certain people
can thrive in that
right because chaos one what about the
people that took this period off
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] what about the people
that
left the places and went like people
that just
didn't fight this out well does that say
something about their
their character they're different
between leaving they're different
between leaving
and not fighting okay because like i
think la is
horrible the way that this oh it's a
horrible place everything's [ __ ]
close it's horrible it's
when it's not
i'm not going to say the available but
like a very nice
restaurant in new york i had a party of
like
12 people right right we're all good
because we're getting tested for netflix
right
i know right literally everybody does
not have corona
right right right for a fact of course
so we're having a little celebration
i look at cert certain people where i go
like i was like
i feel like some people rose to the
occasion in terms of just working yeah
just work
yeah yeah i love working right yeah i
was a drug addict so if i'm not working
i'm in trouble doing drugs
correct so at the end of the day i just
look at certain people and i go and i
get it if you're a young comic i get it
i get like no no yeah yeah you're right
about the restaurant good point you're
not wrong they said they said number
10 people yeah it has to be under 10
people i call the guy i'm like hey i got
12 people ever
can you do this of course that's new
york everything's negotiable it's
negotiable everything's negotiable so
it's like
did people think oh new york is all shut
down nothing's shut down right i get a
slice of pizza if i want to figure it
out
whatever but the same thing it's like yo
if you're a young comic and you're
getting paid by the government to not do
anything
and you're better creating [ __ ] you're
crazy [ __ ] nuts dude yeah which is
i'm proud of the dudes that i work with
you know
ben always you know my that kid dan that
opens for me was out there in florida
making stuff like
when you see people making stuff it's
it's positive
ben works his ass off all the time like
to just make the show better
this whole studio is him this i have
nothing to do with this studio right
literally i mean i walked in i saw i'm
like it's amazing
i have nothing to do with this studio
yeah i mean ben
coordinated this entire thing yeah so it
it's like just
find i think a way to work yeah and
don't wait like there's too many people
right now that are like waiting they're
like waiting
for someone to open the barn door it's
like guys
like they get upset at us i think a lot
of times
and it's i think it's because
they don't like the fact that we took
our career in our own hands
right and i think it kills them that
they exist on the charity
of others yes where we exist on
connectivity of people like my career is
because people [ __ ] with me
and that's always been the way it was
that's it like if i ever was on a show
the executives never really liked me
they would test it you know what it's
called like focus group or something
yeah yeah focus group they focus group
it and then like i do really well and
they're like oh i guess people like this
kid
right right so for me put me in front of
the people give me the people that's all
i care about
i want to say especially with the
[ __ ] netflix thing like i want to
express what i think
most people are actually feeling and
nobody's [ __ ] saying or very few of
us are saying
and it's like that's where i put my
faith in i literally
put my faith in p i have tons of faith
in people yeah
i don't but i they find me funny and
that's okay like
that is yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
finally
no but i get in a way i do because they
finance they fun things like listen
at the end of the day i do think people
can recognize uh
funny yes i think they can recognize
funny and like being authentic
yeah it's like people i don't know it's
not that [ __ ] hard people act like
being like
like a talent exec is a hard job it's
like we make it no it's not
it's not a hard job at all yeah it's
like i could tell you're funny yeah like
when i saw the videos i was like oh yeah
this guy's
funny yeah you know i mean like ryan
long we were talking about anything
funny like i could tell he's got it you
got it right so it's like and then i see
certain people and i go you're trying
really hard you don't have it yet
maybe you won't ever get it but you
might get it but you might get it but
you don't have it yet
yeah and that's just what it is what's
the that so that's interesting maybe to
end on
what is the differential between
eventually getting it
and never getting it and and is it even
something that we even know
i think it's just an unknown i think
it's like
i think some people have something that
is
that almost everybody can attach on to
it's like lizard there's like a lizard
quality to it where it's just like oh
this
is funny like [ __ ] what is his name
chris farley or whatever
yeah like he had a lizard funny yeah i
don't think he said a single
setup punch in his life but when he did
things
it was funny amazing and you laugh right
and it's
lizard right primal [ __ ] right yeah so
some of us have like eddie murphy people
like that too
primal right like bernie mac primal
right like
so it's like some of us have a primal
connectivity right
some people will have 60 000
fans that really relate to their
specific experience and
having that fan base has never existed
in history except right now
maybe with colts so like you might not
have it
where the world will gravitate to you
that's there's only a few of us that are
going to have that
but you have the opportunity with the
internet to find the other 60 000 people
who have existed in life
just like you and you're speaking for
them right
and that has never existed before and
now it has so it's just like figure it
out
yeah find those [ __ ] find the people
find the [ __ ] people
yeah so to me that's why it gets
annoying if i hear bitching about [ __ ]
yeah there's just there's there's enough
avenues out there
dude this comes out when christmas or
something uh the 26th yeah yeah the day
after christmas
so new year's is coming yeah what do you
what do you say yeah you say
2020 was crazy here
yeah very good for you good for me bad
for many
bad for many yeah but isn't that every
year
this one's a little this was a little
extreme
2021 yeah what are we thinking
okay so what is it like every every uh
correction is an over correction i think
is that what you say
yes so so if every correction is an over
correction are we
over correcting joy so like
right if this this year was over
correcting sad
sadness yeah it is next year like we're
just going to lean into the things that
make us feel good
yeah and is it too much even and then
maybe 2022 we start going
let's let's even yeah let's level it up
yeah like i think
you said something brilliant this is too
much joy i think i think you're gonna
you said something brilliant in the
beginning it's gonna be a week of like
whoa
yeah whoa yeah and they're calling old
friends like i think people are gonna
call
old friends and then you're gonna be at
lunch with them going man
i liked when we couldn't legally do this
yeah you know
like i appreciate it tell everyone and
they follow you already anyway
but tell people where to go again this
is saves america on netflix yeah check
it out on netflix and uh that'd be great
man there's a conspiracy
uh uh theories episode that uh i wanted
i really wanted you to see and just see
what you thought
i didn't watch it i'm excited i know
that that's the second episode but like
you know we would always call tim and
ask him
you know i love when you call because i
love just talking yeah yeah yeah you
know
this really well and i know a lot of it
you know in a funny way too that's
another thing like yeah
some conspiracy folks like there's two
things yeah it's
my conspiracy is like late night wendy's
parking lot yeah
like that's really what it was like me
and my friends coming down
smoking weed just eating wendy's and
talking [ __ ] and
you gotta make people laugh if you want
their attention they got to make them
laugh yeah
yeah and that's what trump that's what
trump did you know
he got our attention by making us laugh
yes that was
comedy so it's like yeah i mean that's
the other thing and in closing it's like
if you're out there
and you don't have somebody's attention
[ __ ] make them laugh make them laugh
and you'll get their attention andrew
schultz thank you
once again thanks for having me brother
thank you